l'ars a profité s'apprendre l'issue de
ces discussions éléments de réponse avec
gérard vesper analyste géopolitique
chercheur associé à la fondation
d'études pour le moyen-orient
revenir à l'accord de 2015 stricto sensu
à savoir par exemple avec un taux
d'enrichissement autorisé de
3,25 pour cent alors que les iraniens
ont annoncé arriver maintenant à 60%
apparaît difficile d'autant plus qu' il
y a maintenant depuis le mois de juin à
teyran une équipe dirigeante qui est
beaucoup plus radicale une position du
milieu donc peut être intéressante
d'envisager en disant nous ne prévoyons
pas à nous occidentaux des contraintes
et des décisions supplémentaires dans
les mois à venir contre vos intérêts
économiques et de votre côté vous rester
dans la position d' enrichissement de
niveaux de stocks d'ide rôle de
d'uranium
identique voyez vous il y à des
opérations dans l'ombre comme les
iraniens on sait mener des cyber
attaques en israël pour dérégler des
réseaux hydrauliques par exemple donc
voyez vous c'est surtout de ce côté là
qu'il faut regarder au cas où il n'y ait
aucun accord ils ont ici la fin du mois
de janvier